je te remercie nous accordé cette
entrevue ça me fait plaisir
alors hier vous avez présenté en conseil
des ministres avec la parité avec la
diversité au delà des symboles
qu'est-ce que ça va changer à la façon
dont fonctionne le gouvernement fédéral
pour moi c'est juste une question de
refléter que le canada est un pays avec
tellement de différentes perspectives de
diversité de pouvoir avoir des gens avec
toutes sortes de différentes
perspectives pour travailler sur cette
gouverne de notre pays devient essentiel
et avoir des collègues avec toutes
sortes de différentes perspectives avoir
des discussions autour de la table de
cabinet qui vont être le reflet des
valeurs des priorités de tous les
canadiens je pense que ça ne peut
qu'amener une meilleure qualité décision
pour les canadiens mais a beaucoup de
néophytes 18h30 selligent évidemment
avec un parcours professionnel
exceptionnel
n'empêche qu'ils connaissent pas les
rouages de la politique c'est pas
risquer cinq ans mais on est qu'il est
bien des gens qui connaissent très bien
le voyage la politique
il y en a d'autres qui amène justement
un renouveau un vent nouveau eu un
engagement de de regarder avec un oeil
de l'extérieur
comment ça fonctionne comment ça devrait
fonctionner vous êtes prêts à payer le
prix pour les erreurs qui vont
inévitablement faire l'important quand
on fait des erreurs et on espère ne pas
en faire mais on sait très bien qu'on va
en enfer c'est de reconnaître l'erreur
de n'offrir des excuses et ensuite de
réparer et de prendre au sérieux je
pense que c'est ce que les gens
s'attendent d'un voisin d'un ami ou d'un
gouvernement alors pour moi d'avoir des
gens profondément responsable redevables
mais aussi qui amène des idées une
perspective qui est sorti de la bulle
politique dans laquelle on se trouve ici
pour moi c'est important pourquoi aucun
gros ministères économiques pour le
québec
frère jean yves duclos a la
responsabilité d'amener notre allocation
canadienne aux familles c'était au coeur
de notre plateforme qui va sortir 315
mille jeunes de la pauvreté et qui va
donner des chances aux familles de la
classe moyenne de pouvoir réussir
c'est le plus gros dossiers économiques
que nous avons offert de 20,2 milliards
de dollars par année
etc c'est notre députée de québec qui va
être responsable mais sont pas les
finances sont pas c'est pas un ministère
des finances il ya plusieurs gros
ministères et ce en forme par exemple il
ya des dossiers importants et à
bombardier qui s'en vient pas tout à
fait ce que vous êtes prêts à faire
votre part pour aider mon gardien
moderne content d'avoir un ministre qui
va se pencher sur cette question qui va
faire des recommandations au conseil des
ministres pour une position de notre
gouvernement parce que pour moi c'est
pas juste le premier ministre qui se
doit décider si le conseil des ministres
au complet si les discussions que nous
allons avoir basé sur les faits basée
sur la réalité que deux mais basée sur
les recommandations d'experts et c'est
pas où est ce que vient mais la porte du
genou vrai je ne ferme pas de porte
c'est le ministre qui va qui va s'y
pencher
c'est une réflexion importante à avoir
mais ça va être fait sur la base de
l'intérêt du canada et des canadiens et
de notre notre économie et pas sur les
intérêts politiques et pourquoi est ce
que vous vous êtes garder le portfolio
des affaires intergouvernementales aubin
parce que ça fait ça fait dix ans qu'on
pouvait
ne manquiez manque de collaboration et
de respect souvent pour les différents
paliers de gouvernement et pour envoyer
un message clair que ce gouvernement va
travailler avec les autres paliers de
gouvernement à partir même du bureau du
premier ministre on sait que malgré les
différents paliers les différents
responsabilité on est en train de servir
les mêmes citoyens à travers le pays on
se doit de collaborer n'est ce pas
toujours l'harmonie entre le fédéral et
les provinces on l'a déjà on l'a déjà vu
tout donc ça va pas être difficile vous
voyez pas ça de si ça va être difficile
être premier ministre c'est difficile
s'il ya toujours des choix difficiles
c'est certain mais en même temps de
pouvoir avoir ces conversations de
trouver oui des points communs mais
aussi de voir où nos des différences
c'est cette tension la ccl conversation
l'eau qui même à de l'amélioration et du
changement de maître de mes meilleurs
services pour les citoyens
est-ce que vous avez déjà été informé de
l'état réel des finances publiques à
vous avez pris jeudi a eu vous avez rom
gouvernement et débriefing
un très haut niveau mais je m'attends à
ce que mon ministre des finances se
penche là-dessus qu'ils présentent dans
l'est dans les mois à venir
un état de comptes complets de ce que le
gouvernement est en train d'avoir comme
situation et que de risques en général
les gouvernements arrive ils disent ah
on n'avait pas vu on n'avait pas su on
nous avait pas dit et finalement les
promesses ne peut pas toujours les tenir
où il faut les retards des mois si vous
vous souvenez pendant la campagne j'ai
très clairement dit que je ne voulais
pas faire ça c'est pour ça que nous
avons fait le pari de la franchise
on a dit on sait qu'on a besoin
d'investissements
on sait pour réaliser nous nos
investissements en infrastructures en
transport collectif pour offrir de
l'aide aux familles de la classe moyenne
pour ceux qui travaillent fort pour se
joindre à la classe moyenne
nous allons entrer en déficit ah ça va
être des déficits modeste mais on va
aller en déficit pour pouvoir investir
maintenant dans nos communautés dans
dans le canada et c'est ce qu'on va
faire alors non il n'y a pas de surprise
qui disent que maintenant on le savait
pas on peut pas livrer sur nos promesses
au contraire on va livrer sur nos
provinces avec deux points d'ancrage
fiscaux d'abord l'équilibré budgétaire
en 2019 2020 tel que promis et de
réduire notre rapport dette/pib à chaque
année bon il ya plusieurs grands rendez
vous qui vous attendent là sur la scène
internationale alors parlons de ces
dossiers où on aimerait savoir
concrètement ce que vous allez faire
parce que les promesses le premier
dossier
vous allez en parler augyva c'est celui
des migrants des réfugiés
est ce que votre promesse d'amener au
canada 25 mille réfugiés syriens
d'ici la fin de l'année c'est toujours
possible vous y tenez toujours six mois
savez quand on ne fait la promesse que
l'est restait 2
et nous les promesses qu'on a fait nous
les engagements qu'on a fait pendant la
campagne électorale s'était pas basée
sur la corbeille rectorales s'était basé
sur ce que le canada où ce qu'un
prochain gouvernement de concrètement
comment ça pousse au créneau c'est une
approche savary exiger une approche de
plusieurs ministères ça va exiger des
partenariats avec les provinces avec les
municipalités mais aussi que les
canadiens veulent qu'on agisse de façon
responsable de façon réfléchie mais y en
a qui sont inquiets par ailleurs de
cette arrivée massive de réfugiés vous
l'avez vu dans les sondages ou cas
l'année dernière on a des adversaires
qui ont misé sur cette inquiétude les
canadiens ont fait un autre choix
ils ont fait un choix de donner un
mandat d'ouverture de responsabilité
d'un canada ce qui se réengagent de
façon robuste sur la scène
internationale et notre capacité pas
juste d'accueillir des réfugiés mais de
leur donner une capacité de réussite
pour leur famille pour la communauté
pour le pays de contribuer comme toutes
les vagues d'immigrants et de réfugiés
antérieure au plus fin le 31 décembre
c'est ce qu'on vise oui vous allez
commencer et vous allez pour ce nom
commençait avant ça on veut viser de
garder notre promesse d'avoir 25 mille
réfugiés syriens
ici au canada avant le 1er janvier
je veux regarder je me suis beaucoup
d'experts on doute quand ils savaient
loge je sais et il faut le faire de
façon responsable et c'est ce qu'on est
en train de regarder mais c'est encore
notre intention pour le dossier
maintenant 10 des frappes aériennes
contre le groupe armé état islamique
vous avez déjà annoncé que le canada
sont retirés
ne ferait plus d'interventions de frappe
aérienne alors concrètement ces camps
quand est ce que vous mettez ça on a dit
qu'on allait faire le retrait de façon
respectueuse de nos alliés mais de façon
assez rapide et notre nouveau ministre
de la défense nationale est en train de
se pencher sur cette question là dans
ces jours maintenant en train de parler
à nos alliés en train de regarder les
différentes options pour s'assurer qu'on
tienne notre promesse mais qu'on
respecte nos alliés et qu'on continue
des ddd dans la lutte contre l'état
islamique parce que les gens s'attendent
à ce que le canada et les canadiens
s'attendent à ce que le canada continue
de jouer un rôle important contre
l'islam mais est-ce que certains chefs
de gouvernement ont demandé d'attendre
un peu ou de retarder un peu ce disque
lui les chefs de gouvernements
comprennent très bien que ce
gouvernement s'est fait élire sur un
mandat très clair de terminer à ces
frappes
nous allons terminer mais nous allons
rester engagés dans la lutte contre les
donc ça va être remplacé par quoi vous
pensez que le rôle du canada dans ce
conflit quel qu est ce qu il doit juste
aujourd'hui on veut plus faire par
rapport aux réfugiés
or plus faire par rapport à l'aide
humanitaire mais on va aussi continuer
d'être engagé avec nos forces armées
mais dans un rôle de formation plutôt
que de combat donc plus de troupes au
sol pour faire la formation sur les
grilles kurde patients
si les gens de questions que notre
ministre de la défense nationale est en
train de regarder de façon plus
attentifs mais quand vous avez dit au
lendemain de votre élection
l'heureux le canada est de retour nous
sommes de retour sur la scène
internationale ça veut dire que vous
voulez redéfinir un peu le rôle du
canada à l'étranger
alors vous vous le voyez comment vous
pensez que c'est un rôle de médiation
par exemple dans le conflit en syrie est
ce que le canada est ce qu'il faut
intensifier nos efforts diplomatiques
pour mettre fin à ce conflit
le canada a la chance de pouvoir jouer
un rôle très productif dans les dents
les organisme multilatéral au niveau
d'avoir une voie constructive sur la
scène internationale pour aider à
résoudre d
je partagé par bien des pays dans
l'intérêt national dans notre intérêt
que ce soit économique que ce soit au
niveau de la sécurité de la stabilité
nous avons beaucoup à faire pour
rassembler les gens pour créer des
causses au consensus pour augmenter nos
efforts diplomatiques pour être présent
et positif sur la scène internationale
plutôt que tout simplement prendre une
position et l'a crié très fort sans
nécessairement se préoccuper du fait que
ie pas grand monde qui sont en train de
nous écouter sur le climat il ya ce
grand sommet à paris
quel est votre objectif à vous lors de
ce sommet je pense que yoyo deux
objectifs d'abord c'est de démontrer que
le canada est là pour participer
pleinement et pour faire un apport
constructif à ces négociations et
démontrer que nous allons faire notre
part pour réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais deuxièmement notre
objectif c'est de s'assurer que la
planète que tous les pays s'engagent de
façon robuste à faire pareil nous avons
besoin d'empêcher ce réchauffement de
deux degrés de la planète et le canada
doit faire sa part mais doit aussi
encourager et et trouver des façons de
s'assurer que les autres pays aussi
financé me le dire parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'argent qui est en jeu et des
éléments ce niveau là aussi on aurait
dit les pays émergents pas tout à fait
on a des responsabilités à ce niveau-là
et et notre ministre de l'environnement
d'ailleurs
va partir pour pour paris pour le 8 le 8
novembre pour commencer les prix
rencontre à nouveau ministériel pour
préparer cette rencontre s'assigne à
lequel canada va jouer un rôle qu'il ne
jouait peut-être plus depuis un certain
temps nous avons été élus avec d'autres
priorités et le fait que notre ministre
de l'environnement est aussi ministre de
l'environnement et le changement
climatique je pense que les gens voient
que déjà avoir changé le nom c'est
important pour vous oui c'est un peu
évidemment le symbole c'est que ou si on
est un gouvernement qui reconnaît que
les changements climatiques sont réels
et prioritaire mais aussi le grand enjeu
auquel on fait face par rapport à
l'environnement
ce sont des clans qui changement
climatique et et c'est ce que nous
allons adresser n'empêche vous avez déjà
dit que le canada arriverait irait à
cette conférence avec les cibles du proc
du gouvernement précédent et que les
changements ne viendrait que beaucoup
plus tard en fait un moins un hectare
on aurait aimé avoir discuté avec les
provinces dont vous allez faire quoi bon
vrai je suis entré d'ailleurs de
coordonner une rencontre avec les
provinces pour même avant paris pour
pour essayer au moins de leur leur
parlaient tous et chacun pour pourrait
essayer de voir quelle sorte de
positions fortes que nous pouvons
prendre moi ce qui me ce qui me rassure
c'est dans les conversations avec les
les chefs d'état vont être là chef de
gouvernement vont être là le premier
jour le 30 novembre
quelques jours plus tard al seni maires
des grandes villes et j'ai déjà parlé à
monsieur coderre a marre de vancouver à
d'autres acquis qui sont très
enthousiastes de faire partie de la
délégation canadienne pour pour réitérer
à un autre niveau que le canada est là
pour faire sa part dans quelques jours
plus tard si les premiers ministres des
provinces qui vont être à paris pour
parler de leur engagement
lorsqu'on va voir tout au long de cette
conférence idéalement c'est beaucoup
différentes perspectives canadiennes et
devoirs canadienne
qui se rassemblent sur les valeurs et
les bus les mécanismes ça va varier mais
cette idée que le canada est là pour
être un acteur productif et même pour
mener dans certains dossiers
c'est le grand message que le monde a
besoin d'entendre mais vous avez mangé
le mercredi rs que c'est pas ironique
quand même que votre première grande
décision facile de votre gouvernement en
environnement ça va être de décider ou
non vous refusez que 8 milliards d'aud
visés soient déversées dans le fleuve
on a été élu sur une plateforme qui dit
quand on respecte les scientifiques on
respecte les données et les faits et on
respecte aussi les les préoccupations et
les inquiétudes des citoyens et ce sera
notre ministre de l'environnement et des
changements climatiques de bien essayé
de trouver des solutions mais la réalité
c'est que ça fait bien trop d'années que
les gouvernements fédéral n'est pas un
partenaire dans le traitement des eaux
et c'est pour ça que nous avons pris
comme engagement d investissement de 20
milliards de dollars sur 10 ans dans les
dents dans les infrastructures vertes ce
qui comprend les traitements des eaux
usées vous avez promis une commission d'
enquête sur les femmes autochtones
disparues qui sont mortes dont on n'a
pas de nouvelles
cette commission denquête quand est ce
que vous allez l'annoncé en étant très
justement d'autres de coordonner avec la
ministre d ad
des affaires autochtones la ministre de
la justice et de la ministre et le
ministre de sécurité publique et je
pense aussi la ministre mais ça va se
faire rapidement
ça va se faire rapidement c'est une
priorité sur un engagement mais il faut
aussi le faire de la bonne façon et ça
ça veut dire d'écouter les communautés
autochtones qui ont leur mot à dire là
dessus les familles qui ont beaucoup
leur recommandation à faire mais aussi
de reconnaître qu' il ya des preuves
ainsi les endroits qui ont lancé un
début de commission denquête alors nous
une question de rassembler tout ça pour
le faire de façon appropriée pour qu'on
puisse offrir la justice pour les
victimes mais du soulagement pour les
familles un dernier sujet plus personnel
comment est ce que vous allez organiser
votre conciliation travail famille
joaillier hier avec vos enfants
on sait à quel point c'est un métier
exigeant la politique comment vous allez
faire
j'ai eu des exemples assez
extraordinaire dans mes propres par qui
mon père vivait évidemment c'est cet
équilibre famille travaille ma mère et
j'ai des défis au niveau de la santé
mentale mais en même temps mais tous et
des fils qui vivait il était là pour
nous les enfants il avait une présence
qui m'a permis d'avoir quand même une
vie normale équilibré malgré tout ce qui
était anormale qui nous entoure est né
vous même allez venez des limites des
limites
maintenant il faut délimiter faut il
faut savoir que quand ça avec les
enfants je mets de côté le téléphone je
mets de côté les dossiers et je suis
présent avec eux et pas en train de
penser à c'est vrai il faut que je parle
au premier ministre de la france plus
tard ce soir qu'est ce que je vais faire
non
je pense pas à ça je pense à mes enfants
mais aussi dans l' équilibre à quel
point ils sont à impliquer ou visible
dans les médias c'est c'est un équilibre
à faire on veut qu'ils aient eu une
enfance la plus normale possible tout en
comprenant que ils ont la chance et donc
la responsabilité de
vivre dans un contexte particulier et ça
vient avec des hauts et des bas est-ce
que vous avez une ministre qui disait
hier - entre 4h et 6h je m'occupe de mon
enfant et c'est non négociable
on appelle ces conversations là encore
parce que je pense que c'est parce à
faire de la politique autrement aussi
tout à fait et je peux vous dire que et
j'ai demandé ce matin on m'indique
autour de la table du conseil des
ministres
on a des parents de plus que 50 enfants
josh a alors oui on va changer ses
priorités là et c'était d'ailleurs un
message c'est équilibre cette
réconciliation aux familles enfin est
essentiel de travailler famille parce qu
on est politicien et on sert nos
concitoyens pas en dépit du fait que
nous sommes parents mais bien à cause du
fait que nous sommes car nous voulons
bâtir un meilleur monde pour nos enfants
pour tous des toutous tous les enfants
canadienne est de rester ancrée dans
notre nos priorités personnelles et
familiales ça nous permet d'être
meilleur en tant que les deux là on va
voir jusqu'où jusqu'à quel point vous
allez changer les choses
merci beaucoup il se trouvait ça me fait
toujours plaisir fut